this one's gonna be hard and you're
gonna face a point in this where you're
gonna want to stop where you're gonna be
where you think you're gonna be done and
are you gonna tell yourself that's the
moment that's the moment they just found
something inside of them they didn't
they
we hear it we say it we believe it but
can we see the effect
the games online you can see in a
person's eyes it's noticeable the effect
they make the players around them better
the effector welcome to the in factory
the bus riders required that you better
switch your mind to get ready to take in
the next two hours of what you're about
to do so it's like here it is like it's
now the cool legacy bottle 11 is they
know that they're gonna be challenged or
do something like this so when it hits
them that I go gay now's the time those
that have success too early that haven't
faced the rumbling and the tension and
the struggle is a disservice that takes
place for you it's the struggle where we
find out who we are that is the game
it's at the moment of test that you
really understand how you've orientated
and designed your life go we said hey
we're starting this volleyball court
you're gonna go down to that lifeguard
stander to do some up downs then you're
headed to the next life person they
don't know where the next lifeguard
stand is you can't see it and it's about
a quarter of a mile away
this is best man fights the hardest and
wins we had to run halfway to the Second
Life arts and do 10 up downs go touch
the Second Life headstand turn around
ten up downs and then finish and by the
time you got done with your first ten up
downs you want to quit
when the first wave of kids were coming
back and the intensity of their panting
the exhaustion that they were
experiencing that impacted this secondly
do what they're not willing to do do
what they're not willing to do let's go
I just tell myself just keep going keep
going keep going don't give up you can't
give up you're here you're in Los
Angeles you can't give up they're just
tapping out except for one kid one kid
started on one speed and ended on one
speed that's Dylan McCaffrey other guys
were given their best - but he shredded
fog rolling in it was almost like a
mystical morning but that second I'd say
like 150 yards it was real tiring but it
was it was some really good work it's
almost as if Dylan McCaffrey smiled as
if it was getting harder it was
something very different you know and it
brought me out of my comfort zone and I
think that's what Coach dillford was
trying to embody into each and every
single one of us
how do you perform
in the comfort zone facing adversity you
find out a lot of budget so finite
affected that that you push yourself for
we have one more test but it's your job
as a unit to nominate one guy this might
be the hardest thing you do we're in a
gimmick play here you go all the way up
come down and then give me every element
of the play I've been living in Southern
California for 13 years I've never seen
one person make it all the way up
running on cents
shoot out of the gates they rip into
this thing I'm halfway up and I'm
looking at these stallions charging up
and they're not even looking left and
right they are so locked in and focused
after battling through the whole
mountain itself
and then you have to come back down and
give him the formation I know these guys
knew the answer and they couldn't give
it because they were so broken
physically once they got to the bottom
go all right dad
wrong gun right no number three is this
backside with brown okay come to that
and winner winner chicken I'm creating
anxiety and that's ultimately what you
have to learn how to deal with is do I
have enough to overcome it was a perfect
tee up for it they're gonna do when
they're going through their pro day so
this year we added pro day workout see
these guys on NFL Network and they're
getting right for the draft
all the guys the jams the head coaches
surrounding it there's a lot of pressure
on there it's routes on air your shorts
and a t-shirt you try to put them in
positions where you can see them make
all the throws it's super challenging
it's not just take three steps and hit a
slant take five steps and throw a hook
we're gonna get 21 throws in in less
than seven minutes take okay get your
debt huh spin guess guys head around let
it go yeah perfect feet perfect nice
throw
good good good good okay we explode
people think oh you're just throwing
over air you're throwing over air while
they're watching your footwork they're
watching your eyes they're watching
shoulder and you're the only one going
the cameras are watching the other
twenty three guys they're all watching
that's three you get a rating a score
based off every throw and it's just
where the ball finishes she go she go
just an absolute you know dime was a
three if it was a catchable ball on him
and a great spot they got it too if it
was anywhere in the vicinity that they
caught the ball it was a one so on so on
oh no ha ha ooh no ma'am
if they just flat dirted it or overthrew
it or missed it they got a goose egg say
egg over easy they're not good good
Shawn good Shaun Robinson is to me one
of the top four or five physically
talented guys in this class 62 224 five
track speed powerful arm we haven't seen
Shawn at his best he's been a little
nicked up a lot of people like you know
look at me as athlete but I took my
hamstring you're taking five you're
making the move getting out to the left
first one's deep over I won't be able to
go fast yeah you don't have to go fast
we're good with that just play ball fun
yep he just couldn't perform at the
level that I've seen him perform at did
it go
that's fine that's fine that's fine good
bro ooh this is gonna sound so harsh but
it's the reality availabilities your
best ability in competition may be the
greatest player the greatest competitor
if you're not available they're gonna go
find somebody else he's competing his
butt off he's doing what he can but it's
also not consistent as some of the other
guys this was the fire-pot time yeah the
heck what makes me different I'd say is
for how many things I'm involved in
wrestling track golf baseball football
all these sports have valuable life
lessons that teach you how to be one a
better athlete to a better person -
rocky started off Rocky
he started off rough if you were to do a
golf analogy his front nine score was
was pretty bad ah that's a zero not
exactly sir we want I've been in so many
competitive situations at a high level
that the pressure element doesn't get to
me
that wasn't super consistent but you
know who expects me to be it's baseball
season right go ahead
give it to him yes he's heating up this
is like NBA Jam along this process you
always come across kids who are not very
highly ranked or haven't been seen as
much chase garbage the football junkie
you can see that the pro day didn't
flush him at all because he knew the
PlayBook inside and out he has a mental
capacity that was one of the top in the
class we expected greatness from these
other guys and here comes chase he
killed it he crushed it Tony this dude
might get in there I thought he had a
good day yesterday 33 36 39 a new leader
in the clubhouse chase Garver's
as the lights came on the stadium there
wasn't a guy that clearly separated
himself on the pro day script
ice ball I love competition
the regionals yeah I didn't get invited
on the spot and you know same here I
didn't make the a you know the illegal
evan ranking so just kind of added a
little more fuel to the fire oh yeah we
got a new leader in the clubhouse miles
Brendon at 43 what I was looking for for
to uh for his pro day was the discipline
every concept that we have requires him
to do stuff that he's not accustomed to
doing I think for him it was a moment of
let me show you how hard I've he took
time after his high school practices to
go with his dad to the park to work on
taking jobs from under second to work on
his footwork to prove that he was
disciplined
what we know that to a tango bi-lo can
throw on the run but seeing him in
pocket that was special
you're cool
nice two of the dual threads own read
whatever you want to call him you could
throw that out the window it was two of
the passer true that's perfect
Trey
okay that's a three Oh
literally jaw-dropping pro-day stuff oh
I could have put him with Andrew locks
pro day that's how good to his pro day
script puts yeah okay here gotten so
much better
Betty jumpy she thank you thank you 45
Dear Leader
all right guys ah
we need to hone in on six through 17
because you could easily see a guy jump
I would put him from 6 yeah he just had
an exceptional day down at the beach a
power of coming through the sand with
his current stature was super impressive
to me he diesel that whole workout and
he won by 60 yards fresh obviously a
special kids special family I could see
him winning the opening the one other
change - uh yeah so private here he had
an exceptional day he's come from 16 to
11 date and it's all warranted so we
have nine from the eleven and then
there's this group in the middle Shaun
Robinson I don't think he's in the
discussion right now I don't think he's
out of the discussion but I don't think
he's like on the razor's edge of it fair
I think Shaun Robinson has better
physical tools in all of them but he is
not in one piece right now and it's not
coming together like it needs to Sam
thing about Sam that I love he's tougher
than nails he runs the ball he's a great
leader he's been through a ton I seen
him improve his passing my only
reservation of sand that he this is you
yeah even the press especially in big
moments yeah that it does maybe get a
little today I'm a DeVito guy he said he
wanted to come out and rip it yeah
that's exactly what he did
miles he's done a ton of good things but
there are guys that are just better on
the field so far in in this group it's
it's more prominent cuz there are so
many yeah prehospital great that's a
great point so I think we have four that
are looking at two spots
I'm a black belt I climbed out will yell
at you opening and I play quarterback
I am the best singer among the 24 cubies
yeah so they asked me what my head
factor was told him I was my hair